this project is an effort to produce the
21st century biology textbook that is
going to inspire students to learn about
science whether they are going to be
scientists or not to create a window
into the scientific process X bio adopts
a storytelling approach the narratives
of discovery are told by scientific
leaders in a particular field and even
sometimes the discoverers themselves
these stories are adventures but they
revealed the humbling truth that
scientists often make mistakes and they
go down the wrong path but that's part
of tackling the unknown and what X bio
does it is that it demystifies
scientists and it explains who they are
and what they do the humanity that
underlies the people that are doing the
science and that comes in all different
flavors which is science is mostly about
failing
so it's Humanity of persevering it's the
joy of actually finally getting the
success for me science is about
discovery it's about what's new it's
about what we don't know it's not about
memorizing what we know what's thrilling
about science is how scientists make
discoveries and that's what X biowing
lets you in on you're in the process of
how science gets done how discoveries
get made and how that changes the world
we're bringing these stories to life
with great text that's interesting to
read beautiful illustrations created by
talented artists videos that really
capture the human side of science I
think what's exciting for me about this
project is as an artist getting the
opportunity to work with scientists
educators filmmaker
technology developers all coming
together to create a great learning
experience what makes this project very
very exciting is part to me as a
scientist it's an experiment in
education I think it's going to give
students a much better sense of why
they're in that classroom learning about
science why does it matter and how
information is actually generated if we
can tap into that fundamental passion
and show them that that's really what it
is to be a scientist it's it can be a
kid your whole life it's great an
important element of this whole project
is a social equity component many
textbooks now cost $250 and we'd like to
make this project freely available so
that any student around the world can
learn about the life sciences one of the
reasons I'm so passionate about this
project is a promise that we have the
chance to make many of these tools and
tools of critical thinking available
freely to the widest group of students
whoever you are and whatever you do
curiosity about life is fun an
understanding how science works makes us
all better global citizens
the truth is there's scientists in
everyone come explore biology with us
you